dix mois sophie duez bio julie
devrais-je tulle et choisit plutôt
gironde tes partenaires non
je sais pas j'ai tourné aussi avec
balasko lavanant je ne dis pas qu'elles
soient pas gironde mais tu as dit quand
le réalisateur est une actrice c'est
mieux style godard karina par exemple il
ya quelque chose non plus tu as dit
alors avec godrèche et quelque chose en
plus les quelque chose en moins mais
avec godrèche qui a le talent en plus de
tous et donc
qu'est-ce que de quoi un metteur en
scène pourrait-il rêver si ce n'est
d'avoir en face de lui une comédienne
qui a un talent extraordinaire et qui
est extraordinairement le personnage tu
refuses pas l'épithète de pervers que tu
préfères un malsain peut même dire que
tu l'as eu un seul mot peur malsain est
totalement négatif disons que malsain
c'est un pervers raté mais
c'est bien la perversion c'est comme le
sait comme le piment dans la cuisine
asiatique c
dis moi me coûte est toujours aussi
obsédé par la mort ah oui oui bien sûr
bien sûr tu crois pas que si tu croyait
en dieu c'était vrai à vivre
certainement ça j'en suis absolument
certain
mais on ne décide pas de croire et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus